[Music]
hello it's 1:55 as we all know this is
the time when your circadian rhythms
pashya body into the most alert state
ready to learn about Kafka so if you're
here to learn about appacha Kafka and
confluent cloud they managed Kafka
service on GCP you're in the right place
if you are here to learn about stream
analytics and ingestion and delivery of
event streams to real-time applications
you are also in the right place if you
are not here for any of these things
you're also in the right place because
surely these topics will become
important for your organization
sooner than later my name is kir I'm a
product manager in Google cloud platform
and I work on stream ingestion and
delivery this means that I spend my day
working with users of Google cloud
pub/sub our native ingestion and
delivery service and users of Kafka the
open source event ingestion and delivery
system and today I'm finally able to
extend a proper welcome to the Kafka
users to GCP now that we have a managed
service to talk about now this has been
a long time coming I try I try thank you
for those Snickers see now I don't have
to ask you to raise your hands if you
run cough Korean production or not and
for everyone else no worries I'll catch
you up in a second and apologies for the
bad joke
so here's how we'll do this I will spend
a few minutes setting the stage I will
talk about what we mean by streaming
ingestion and delivery what companies do
with stream ingestion and delivery
systems we'll talk about application
patterns and I will answer the question
of when does it make sense to use Kafka
on GCP even though we have a native
service and then I will do my real job
and get out of the way of the engineers
and have boy gasping uncommon stage
bogie is a director of engineering at
the New York Times who has put a kafka
cluster on the way of every single piece
of published content in this large media
company he'll tell us why and what they
did for his company and the cost of
running Kafka in that critical role and
once we've once we've gotten through
that
Gwenn Shapira the senior architect from
confluent and a longtime cough card we
could we'll come and share confluence
vision for what happens when Kafka and
the entire ecosystem of Kafka tools by
easily accessible within an organization
and she will give you the demo as well
so let's let's get into it streams of
events everywhere we're getting
increasingly increasingly good at
capturing interactions with devices
digitizing them so this is no secret and
as engineers were increasingly often
challenged with turning these streams of
events into useful features useful
interesting entertaining things for for
our users so for example in gaming and
media we're using in session user
activity to adjust gameplay as users
play we're adjusting content based on
browsing history and we're certainly
adjusting the advertisements as they
show up now in e-commerce well first of
all if you in e-commerce you already
also are in the e-commerce and media
business but you're also building
recommendation systems right and so the
recommendations that you show me on page
two had better know what I just did on
page one 15 seconds ago in finances is
of course been a long-standing problem
well let's say the risk group needs to
aggregate events that are trades in
various departments of a bank as well as
the as well as all the market activity
that's that's happening outside so
what's new is the sheer scale now it
used to be so so people say maybe twenty
years ago you could you could have a
very successful large business with a
thousand person call center generating a
hundred events per second any messaging
middleware kept up with that and things
were great zoom to now and I'm routinely
speaking to customers of JCP ingesting
thousands hundreds of thousands millions
events a second and doing something
useful with them in real time so what we
need is not just messaging middleware
but a high throughput ingestion and
delivery system for streams of events to
make sense of all of us and of course
Kafka is sort of become the de facto
standard of this kind of system in the
open-source community so I wanted to
take a couple minutes to just walk you
through some of the kind of prototypical
patterns that I see when I talk to users
of Kafka and cloud pub/sub
on an example of a sort of a
hypothetical e-commerce business that
got its hands on a high throughput
ingestion and delivery system for
streams of events so the journey usually
starts with collecting user interaction
event for events for analysis if you're
going to create a useful experience for
your customers you need to have your
analysts and data scientists go to the
warehouse and and actually figure out
what's working and so the way we build
this is I'm shopping for for shorts and
flip-flops so I'm I'm viewing the shorts
page on my mobile device I tap on the
shorts that generates a request to state
this front end that front end is
stateless because it's able to take
advantage of a high throughput event
ingestion API to persist the event it
just publishes it right through no
longer has to worry about writing it to
disk no longer has to worry about
writing it to the database returns to
the user on the other side now we we use
the delivery side of the API to start
building processing pipelines so we'll
start with the data flow pipeline that
just grabs the events parses them turns
them into structured data
puts them in the warehouse so a bigquery
of course soon enough you realize that
you don't actually need all the data you
need some aggregates are filtering so
you just keep adding these pipelines as
you understand what you need the
beautiful thing is your front ends are
stateless your back ends can you can add
your backends whenever you wish because
in the middle there is this there's this
thing that is able to scale with the
throughput and and decouple the two
systems so once you've done this you or
data scientists make their first
discovery and you're ready to create
your first feedback loop they discover
that users tend to buy things they've
seen before
and so we so we want to build as a
simple feature where when I'm browsing
for shorts I want to see the history of
all the shorts that I've seen before all
right I'm just the strip of my user
history so we will build a recently
viewed service every time a request
comes in for a product page the front
ends reach into the service with a with
a user profile and get back a list of a
list of products I've browsed perfect
very simple the question is how do we
populate the user history and that's
simple as well just another and another
data flow pipeline a browsing event
comes in a page view you grab the user
ID product ID stuff it into BigTable now
you have a profile so this is working
your revenue is going up you're happy
your boss is happy you're ready to take
the next step which will illustrate
another kind of common pattern which is
handling events that are not that I just
changes in a database alright we're
doing change data capture and so the
goal now is to capture it changes in a
in a database of an existing service and
materialize them in something else so
what we want to do now is build an
experience where when I'm browsing for
shorts I get a recommendation for
flip-flops because they're relevant not
my browsing history right so we're
building you might like the service that
has a product graph you give it a
Product ID it gives you other product
IDs we don't get this from the customers
activity stream but we might have an
inventory management service or some
other similar system that your buyers
use to sort of select and onboard
products to you ecommerce store and
they're writing they're writing content
there may be saying this comes in
such-and-such color it's such-and-such
brand this is this is starting to look
like useful data that you can use to
build build a product graph except that
the day basis is provisioned for your
buyers right these are the ten people
I'm for responsible for what products
are sold not the million end-users you
have I'm so to do so to deal with that
problem we captured a change stream from
from the product database turn it into
events and from there we can build any
number of materialized views of that
such as the product graph so these are
the common patterns now out of habit
I've been showing you i'm GCP hexagon
cloud pub/sub my first product at Google
so forgive me but of course in reality
Kafka does all of these things and
increasingly not just ingestion and
delivery but also stream processing with
K streams and K sequel so the question
is why would you want to use Kafka on
GCP an orgy well it turns out that the
answer to this question is there these
three reasons why you would mmm there
are many others but it's it turns out to
be often the right choice so reason
number one is is easy migration you're
rarely migrating to Cod because you're
unhappy with your Kafka cluster you're
probably migrating because you want to
change change you warehouse so maybe you
want to take advantage of google
kubernetes engine for to run your
application front-ends Kafka will will
migrate happily in live in cloud so no
reason to change change what doesn't
need to be changed second is if we take
a step back you're when you start
migrating you're probably building a
hybrid environment maybe that's part of
your sort of long term migration
strategy maybe that's the end state
where you want to land and so in this
case you want your data exchange and
access layer to be something that works
both on premises and across public
clouds so a native service like cloud
pub/sub is not the natural solution in
this case and you will see cough Kay and
conflict cloud in particular I'm very
good at this problem and then finally if
you're doing if you're doing event
sourcing so you're this Kafka is
absolutely the right starting place
event sourcing takes advantage of
Kafka's particular way of doing event
ingestion and delivery which is that
which is it's it's a complete vlog right
it allows you to store events as they
come in in an append-only log and then
serve them out in order when you have a
complete log that you can read with high
throughput many many times over you can
use it to store the the set of changes
to a state or database and then
materialize that database as many as
many times as you want without putting a
load on your source database as you
might do if you for example we're
experimenting with something that takes
a lot of different materializations like
an elastic search cluster so I've done
sourcing hybrid systems and quick
migrations and three very good reasons
to start
cough con GCP of course easy succeed now
you have a problem you have to run Kafka
well running Kafka well turns out to be
hard as really any system but I'm a
product manager remember I don't get to
run anything in production they don't
let me well what what I do get to do is
I do get to meet people who do so I'd
like to invite borgir to tell you if his
experience running Kafka at the New York
Times thank you so what we using Kafka
for at the Times is making published
content available to our readers and
this is what that looks like so we have
a blog post out that describes how that
actually works I'm not going to go into
detail on that now only to say that this
is an example of event sourcing or
specifically a log based architecture so
the core principle in this is that we
maintain a log of every asset published
by the New York Times since the
beginning of 1851 and up until events
being published in real time and now I
hope since we're all here this week
there are two main principles for
running such a log
we need to two main requirements we need
ordered playback because the publish
events we are writing to the log have
causal relationships between them so the
ordering matters and the own the other
thing is that we need infinite retention
we want this to be available forever an
only Kafka fulfill
both of those requirements
now it's because Kafka is such a
critical piece of our infrastructure the
news don't get out here if our Kafka
cluster is down and that's a very big
deal at the Times so because of that we
put a lot a lot of work of effort into
keeping this Kafka cluster available and
reliable so we have a dedicated team of
engineers running it and more concretely
we're running this on GCE we might have
chosen gke if we had started over now we
have an ansible script that handles all
our Kafka deployments rolling updates
and all of that we have set up
multi-region replication using mirror
makers so everything published one Kafka
cluster it becomes available everywhere
latency is is very important to us since
this is news so we also have implemented
our own log off set monitor that lets us
know if one of these log consumers fall
behind and we're also taking full
advantage of Kafka's ACL specifically to
limit rights because anything being
written to this copper cluster and goes
directly onto the site so we have to
keep very tight control and who gets to
write to it in in addition to all of
this we're also very conservative in how
we use the cluster so for instance we
don't allow other teams at the times to
use this cluster for their own things
and as a consequence of that using
things like Kafka streams Casey : Kafka
Connect is a lot harder than we would
want it to be and in spite of all of
these things still sometimes go wrong so
so Kafka is highly available in the
sense that if a broker goes down things
are still fine when all the brokers are
logging excessively and run out of disk
at the same time that doesn't really
help it also didn't help us when we
configure mutual SSL authentication and
our whole communication between our
Kafka workers stopped very suddenly
which also brought the entire cluster
down maybe the most frightening case
we've seen was when one of our consumers
had it's offset reset and immediately
starting creating a version of the New
York Times home page with old news which
is really not something we want luckily
we managed to stop that before it got to
the reader but we we do we do remember
that day and basically as a Technology
Strategy at the Times we want to run
manage services whenever we can it's not
- we we want to be good at news we don't
want to be good at running
infrastructure and the reason we run our
own Kafka our all and put on put in all
the time and resources and attention to
that is because when we started this
project two years ago there was no
manage Kafka on TCP as I had long
discussions with care about when
News and not at running kappa we on the
other hand that confluent our kind of
crappy news on the other hand we were
very very good it's running kava
we've been running Kafka in production
our team since the first lines of code
for Kafka were ever written at LinkedIn
about a year and change ago we announced
a controlled cloud as a way to let us
manage your Kafka in the public cloud
now in order to really see the value of
what we're doing here I want to take you
few years back back to the days were of
Kafka still in first invented at
LinkedIn 10 years ago we started seeing
the microservices trend and the more
micro services we had the more databases
each micro service had the more lines of
communication going back and forth
between micro services and database the
our entire infrastructure became very
complex very hard to manage now I'm not
going to this talk is not about
simplifying the complexity of IT even
though that's a good topic of discussion
it's about how you can help here and
really simplify your architecture so you
have one who I write run Apache Kafka
you can now have connections between the
different applications and Kafka
everything that is every vendor this
publish to Kafka is available to
everything and this obviously greatly
simplifies you bill decentralized
architecture that allows you to deploy
new services and give them access very
easily to all the data that your
organizational health at scale in a very
reliable distributed system now of
course the messy infrastructure once we
started doing cloud migrations and
hybrid cloud it did not get any better
in fact it got a lot worse we took the
master to head in one data center and
now we have a mess in five the other
centers and in this cloud provider and
in the other cloud provider and now that
it's going on public cloud it has real
costs and it has real security risk so
from the mess just got a lot more
expensive so think about the same
architectures that simplify
micro-services deployment on prem now
applied for both cloud migration and in
the cloud it really allows you to have
one channel of communication to secure
each event is replicated once which
drives down costs and you have this nice
much easier to manage and monitor
architecture out there but that's not it
because you have all the data available
in Kafka four streams you can start
experimenting with everything the clouds
have to offer
you want to try data flow you want to
try tensor flow you want to try bigquery
even if you never did it before you're
totally a MySQL shop very easy to just
stream events from Kafka to bigquery and
running experiments so you really have a
lot more possibility out there and this
is really the vision that inspired
Apache Kafka connect everything to
everything from on purim to the cloud
micro services and databases and make
all the data available to the entire
organization kind of breaking down all
those silos vision but when building a
platform it's not just about the
platform itself that's a lesson that we
all learned from eBay you build a
platform to sell stuff but the point is
the stuff you actually sell the power of
this centralized platform is from the
things that connect to the platform that
bring in the data and take out the in
from create value to the business the
value is really in the micro services in
the ecosystem so confluent includes a
lot of components that makes it very
easy to create those very lively
ecosystems that make data available for
organization one of the coolest ones is
schema registry which allows you to make
changes to the schema of the events to
the data that you are transmitting
independently between the producer of
the data and the consumer so the
producer wants to make some changes and
you can do it in a very safe ways our
journey is all about making change and
evolution safe another cool tool is cask
you realizing Borg I mentioned it it
allows you to create stream processing
applications using a very familiar
secret like language
we also have clients in pretty much
every language you're seeing like eight
here there's like 50 of them confuse if
you like PHP here you go Kafka PHP
clients that's kind of the power of open
sources at once you have an open
protocol everyone can create clients
you're not depending on anyone to do it
for you
now we mentioned databases and
integrating micro-services and databases
is really what allows you to run your
entire organization of one stream of
events Kafka has the kafir' Connect
infrastructure and kapha Connect allows
you to plug in connectors and we have a
hundred plus connectors allowing you to
get data from different databases into
Kafka from Kafka to other databases from
Kafka to another Kafka if you want data
from Vertica to show up in bigquery
people actually do it you have a
vertical connector getting data one way
bigquery connector the other way and you
were good to go this is incredibly
powerful especially since it requires
almost no coding and we run it for you
so that's the whole thing right you
don't you want to use it you want to
gather your data you want to build your
micro services you don't want to
actually run any of it and the reason
you don't want to run any of it is that
Kafka is a distributed system and
running distributed systems is difficult
we should know writing a distribution
systems were difficult enough in the
first place it's kind of tricky but as
we all know you have debugging is twice
as hard as coding you're not allowed to
be as smart as humanly possible while
coding because you need to be twice as
smart while debugging something race
conditions and scheduler timing all this
has been a sort of first sight for a
very long time now Operations is all the
fun of debugging with time pressure
customers yelling at you money picking
away what can be more fun so I want to
just share with you three kind of
reasons that it's a good idea to let
someone else run Kafka for you the first
is that random stuff happens and random
stuff is usually not that good stuff
this is the feathers that we expect to
see we kind of know that this will fail
and machines may fail and the network
will have issues those
we plan for people who forget to renew
their ssl certificates not so much
planned for but the thing is that you
will you have a strong team and you have
you build a strong system that is
capable of overcoming failures we have
the experience and you have the tools
and you have the monitoring in place you
can build very resilient systems the
three keys of this requires experience
and expertise you can build it in-house
a lot of people do Berger has an amazing
team that manages to build something
very resilient but as you said it may
not be your business to do that even
when nothing absolutely fails you still
have to make changes to the system you
can't just say it works today let's not
touch it ever again because even though
there is a risk of change every upgrade
has a risk of new bugs and things going
on there is also a risk of not changing
right we know that if you don't evolve
an adult you'll be left behind
new features actually have values they
allow you to implement things faster and
some people are kind of servers they
cannot use case cure because they know
that it will allow them to move faster
and deliver value faster why not offload
the risk to someone who is being paid to
take this risk and go on your way you
get the benefits and this is really the
key you focus on your ideas we focus on
running Kafka and everything will be
amazing so I want to jump into a demo
kind of kind of semi live demo where I
show you how I actually build one of the
architectures that Kier mentioned
streaming data and joining it and doing
some processing to it using confluent
cloud on multiple clouds so it will be
hybrid cloud Emma okay so you can see
here I have two clusters in confluent
cloud this is the confluent cloud UI you
can see I have AWS and GCP I'm going to
move data between them if I you can see
how big my clusters are huge right okay
those are demo clusters I want to create
a new cluster I can choose a name and
then I can choose how large or small the
cluster is going to be which cloud is
going to be on and you can see that as I
changed my cluster configuration the
pricing on the right can
automatically adjusts to reflect my new
cluster if you pay a lot of attention
you can see the GCP slightly cheaper
than the competitors once I'm happy with
the configuration and you can see that
if I want more storage it's going to be
slightly more expensive than cases where
I want less storage I'm a fan of
configuration I'm happy with the price
I'm happy with my setup I go in in this
case I'm cancelling and let's see how
you manage those clusters that I now got
so you can see here this is the list of
topics that I already have in my DCP
cluster and then if I go to AWS you can
see the list of topics that I have an
AWS cluster and suppose if I want to see
what is in the topic I can look at this
scheme I mentioned the schema registry
and that allows me to keep comparable
you can see it in this topic I have
users and you have the usual suspect
fields I have user ID and region and
Jenner and kind of the stuff I want to
know about those users now suppose that
I want I have those users in AWS and you
know maybe they arrived from an
s-something the dumps data in s3 I also
have maybe some pageviews I have a bunch
of stuff running on AWS but I really
want to process it on GCP because GCP
has things like tinsel flow and peak
where you know a lot of stuff that I
really enjoy using like as a developer
you always have your favorite tools and
some of them happen to be in GCP getting
data from cloud to cloud is actually a
hard problem this is something that you
think it's going to be easy until you
basically go and try to do it and I
figure out that if you all you know is
the stuff within your cloud it's not
they're not going to help you move
anywhere else conference replicators
that is based on kafir Connect basically
allows you to copy some data so you go
into kafir connect and you choose what
topics you want to copy so you can have
a white list a black list maybe
everything except the test topics a
regular expression you can basically
type in the topics that you want to copy
and then you can see a bit down you have
which where does the data come from in
this case it comes from AWS and a bit
further down it's going a lot of
security configs and it's going to be
worse the data going to it's going to GC
once I'm happy with the oh one more
configuration to talk through I can
rename the topics so I can say that the
topic was used to could be called a WS
dot users I want to rename it to start
with GCP so it'll kind of make a bit
more sense and know where that is came
from where it went to what is the topic
you those here are called topic names
are kind of common once I'm happy with
the config I just go ahead start this
connector replicator and let's go and
see the topics in GCP so here we go as
we did the rename so it's GCP dot a WS
dot users now the first thing I want to
check is that my scheme arrived intact
that my data is more or less the way I
expect it to be so I go in and say Brau
schema once again and you kind of say
yep looks the same I have the region the
gender everything that I expected now
let's go back and see what is the data
actually like so we go to a different
topic you'll remember replicated two
topics the pageviews and my users let's
go to the page views a newscast QL to
see what is the data in my topic so I do
query using SQL and it's the first thing
I have to do is create a stream which is
basically a materialized view on top of
the topic I have one already existing so
no big deal
and once I go in you can see it's very
simple I do select star run the query
behind the scenes it starts a stream
processing job a consumer and pretty
soon you'll see a stream of events on
the screen and this is a live stream of
events you can see the user ID and the
page the user is viewing you can see the
timestamp and as data keeps coming into
the topic you can see that I have more
and more events to go through you can
see this is a pretty busy topic so you
can see that we are accumulating more
and more events in there now this is
kind of a simple query suppose if they
want a subset of the events suppose that
I won't only page views from a single
gender in the audience well I need the
page view topic does not have anything
about gender but it has user ID and the
user topic has the gender of each user
so I can join those two streams of
and then do a filter based on the other
field very normal thing this is a
continuous query so it's a query that
basically does an ETL job that runs all
the time the results go into a new topic
now what do I do with results that go in
your new topic well I may want to
analyze them that's why I ended up in
GCP in order to analyze it so what I
want to do is take those events dump
them into say bigquery and now the sky's
the limit right you can use the Google
Data studio and there's tons of tools so
I go again to cover connect and create a
sim connector that uses Google bigquery
as the connector so I pick the topic
page the subset of page views that are
already created I pick the bigquery
connector I give it a name say Google
bigquery and let me start configuring
this topic and you can see it doesn't do
normally feels big worried those are
configurations should be super familiar
which tables do I want the topics to go
into what is the project
what are the field all those things that
I've already used to say once I'm happy
with my configuration I'm click OK and
I'm done and think about it I just this
was a seven minute demo we got data out
of AWS into GCP
who I read it created a continuous
transformation and dumped the data into
bigquery food into further analysis so
this is kind of Fame if I may say so
myself kind of a big deal
it used to be incredibly difficult
because I know I've been trying to do it
for a pretty long time so this is really
one part of the value of having an open
source open standard software is that
you are not locked into a winner you can
deploy and have the same experience in
every cloud and you can easily move
between the clouds now if you remember
two things from this presentation the
first is that streaming platform gives a
lot of value to the business and data
sharing it gives a lot of value to the
business but it really takes an
ecosystem of tools that exists around
Apache Kafka you cannot do it with just
a messaging system you need a lot more
than that and that if you don't want to
go through the pain of having to learn
how to manage it yourself which takes a
while
you may want to run confluent cloud on
publicly out of your choice hey DCP is a
nice one and have make us do it for you
now in order to go home and try it
yourself confident cloud arrives in two
flavours conference cloud and the prize
means that you have to call a
salesperson and talk to them this is our
unlimited scale enterprise level we have
SLA as we have support we have we busy
peering you have security options when
borghi wants to move in to confer cloud
we link that maybe he'll choose to do it
this is probably the options that he'll
use now if you are a team of developers
who want to experiment with kappa you
don't neeed you trusters you don't need
tons of support you just want to try a
bunch of stuff create a lot of clusters
pretty much what I did here in the demo
just spin up a bunch of clusters and try
stuff out confident cloud professional
is the tool for you and your team so I
hope this I hope you'll hole run home
and I'll basically look at our dashboard
and see this uptick in cloud
professional users because you are all
trying it that's it will still be around
for the rest of the event yes so if you
want to catch us with expert questions
that you're shy to ask in public will be
super happy confluent has a boost down
on a
mosconi's house if you want to catch
some of our cloud experts who are going
to be around thank you all for coming
[Applause]
you
[Music]